and stephen brault will take the mound
for the second time in the big leagues
this season spending the majority of
this year on the injured list the 2-1
pitch
lifted in the air deep left field at the
track at the wall gone
lead off homer
tommy edmond
one-nothing cardinals
good job right down the middle 91. i
[Applause]
sending alford back to the track with
room
for the out molina gave it a good ride
tommy edmond did too and edmonds left
the ballpark one-nothing buck's coming
back we'll see jay happ getting the call
tonight for saint louis the 2-2 pitch
strike three called on the outside
corner a good start for j-hat outside
corner
back-to-back case looking for
j-hep a swing and a miss struck him out
another fastball there we go one out
that's that's what i love to see from
brawl right there
[Applause]
paul the young with a drive deep left
field at the wall gone
young with home run number 15 and it's
two-nothing st louis
the 1-1 pitch
and sosa
hits it out to center did they go
back-to-back off the top of the wall and
didn't get over reynolds playing it back
in sosa on his way to third and it looks
to be a triple off the top of the wall
in dead center field there's the 2-2 and
a swing and a miss struck him out
anthony alford at the plate 3-2 pitch
swaying at a miss strikeout number three
here's paul goldschmidt
and for a second time he gets goldsmith
his second time from the fastball
to fastball strike three call zipped it
on the inner edge and molina caught
looking for the first out back to the
top of the batting order boy park
deep to right and hoy park goes
out of the park
his first
in the big leagues
the one-two
got him yeah i feel like if you
see a guy like that that's where you're
gonna attack him right there and mundo
sosa will lead things off 3-2 swing and
a miss he struck about
and now j hat
soft liner to second for the second out
there's a swing of the deep fly ball
toward left
alford back toward the notch onto the
warning track backing up making the
catch near the notch
and that ends the inning
and a fly ball lifted to left dylan
carlson will make the catch so no damage
done one extra pitch and there's one
away
into center
vader
with the catch two outs polanco over two
two fly outs to harrison bader the pitch
on the way check swing strike three
called on the inside corner five
strikeouts for j house
keller is the new pitcher two home runs
hit by the cardinals tonight and another
base hit for dylan carlson three for
three so one out and two one
it's a fastball and it scoots on through
pass newman into left off his glove a
run will score so molina on an o2 pitch
hits it sharply past kevin newman and
it's back to a two-run st louis lead
it's 3-1 yeah that's a mistake right
there right if you're gonna throw that
pitch you gotta throw or the catcher
wants it you can't yank that down over
the strike zone and then
you kind of hope right here your
shortstop at least keep this ball in
front runners at the corners with one
down harrison boehner the one
little flare hit out to center that ball
will drop
aranado will score
he fought it off and that makes it a 4-1
st louis lead on a base hit by harrison
bader
this is what i'm talking you don't have
to pull off to get the hands of the ball
and you don't have to hit every ball
hard you just have to give yourself a
chance
and that's what he does right here he
stays inside the ball he doesn't get too
big
and fortunately it falls in for him
snap throw by stallings and they got him
harrison bader picked off good timing
there nakowski stallings
yeah both guys
that was excellent
beautiful throw and a nice quick tag by
nickowski
and the pitch swinging a miss struck him
out threw it by him fastball in 94
and that ends the inning two runs across
for st louis on three hits and a man
left we'll go to the bottom of the six
it's four to one cardinals
a swing and a high pop-up
fair territory backing up the catch is
made by goldsmith on the outfield grass
just down the right field line
lined and caught it's second by sosa
a bullet into the glove of edmundo sosa
and it stays a 4-1 stables lead 2-2
strike three call and carlson
caught looking to end the seventh so
here is ryan helsley in relief of jay
half payoff pitch coming up check swing
and did he go yeah he did strike three
he's rung out by
ryan blakeney the third base umpire 1-2
right down the middle at 99 and a
strikeout back-to-back case cardinals
not taking any chances they'll go with
the lefty cabrera so lefty lefty match
up here the 01 pitch
up the middle
backhanded
the young and makes the play he was
playing more towards the second base
side makes a backhanded play going to
his right
and we're through seven a 3-2 pitch by
cabrera
and dagowski clearly unhappy with this
fly out
as he aired out his frustrations cabrera
sets and delivers
and a swing and a pop-up back of short
that'll be the second baseman sosa in
shallow center to retire at two-handed
for the second out two gone and castro
will get a chance the two-two
ah
get to the right side sosa nice play
four up four down for cabrera
skin hop jump um
that's harrison bader to lead things off
it's all the same
[Music]
good curveball there strikeout and uh
he's doing good work especially against
right-handed hitters one out walking it
brings in sosa hit the other way and a
nice piece of hitting by soso to young
to second
popped up
and reynolds so
one more chance
and do it against the closer alex reyes
and they're looking for their eighth
straight win in pittsburgh
good pitch good pitch
hit in the air
popped up right side sosa has it and the
cardinals have a 4-1 win
and a game in which
the pitching combines to allow just one
hit
in the nine innings